et avec les nombreux magasins fermés le
commerce en ligne et les drives explose
pour contrer les géants du secteur des
plateformes locales voient le jour et
elle encourage l les circuits courts
regarder ces deux exemples en côte d'or
avec fabienne acosta et d'asnières à
bessèges cliquer acheter et réceptionnés
voilà peut-être la nouvelle routine dû
confiner le site fip choc vient de se
lancer pour concurrencer notamment les
drives des grandes enseignes
mais avec plus de produits locaux et des
livraisons gratuites dans les bureaux de
tabac de côte-d'or et de saône-et-loire
il circule couronne et on les connaît
mais ce qui aujourd'hui pose un problème
par rapport à ces circuits courts c'est
le transport et le transport reste quand
même une une charge assez lourde pour
eux que ça soit je sois en particulier
qui se déplace soit on prend comme on
dit un transporteur pour livrer donc la
livraison coûtent encore très cher et ce
système là fait que la livraison coûtera
pratiquement rien les deux associés
s'appuie sur une plateforme logistique
déjà existantes
les 350 points relais qui
l'approvisionnent chaque jour en jour
nos ce qui justifie les livraisons de
marchandises gratuite
déjà une cinquantaine de commandes ont
été passées ce qui devrait permettre
aussi aux buralistes et aux dépositaires
de se diversifier
ça facilite les retours ça facilite les
discussions sur d'éventuelles
réclamations sur un produit sûr en garde
le lien humain et on croise à cette
chaîne humaine cirque on on humanise le
e-commerce à dijon le e-commerce locale
se vérifie aussi avec les produits qui
ne sont pas de première nécessité après
la crise des gilets jaunes où les
opposants à la réforme des retraites
le confinement empêchent encore
certaines boutiques de travail et un
shopping dijon leur permet de déstocker
leurs marchandises
ce site intervient pile au moment du
confinement
profitez-en pour aider vos commerçants à
survivre parce qu'ils en ont besoin et
il est fait pour ça
ce site aussi mis sur la livraison en
moins de 24 heures consommer sans se
déplacer
c'est effectivement le concept qui
répond à une demande
là c'est vrai que 24 heures et avec du
coup des livreurs dijonnais c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant
s'ils ont tous les deux trouvé une
raison des 30 ans de confinement c'est
plate forme semble avoir aussi le même
raisonnement perdurer et s'adapter à ces
nouveaux modes de consommation en ligne